Vegeta, what does the scouter say about his power level?
It's over 9000!
What? 9000?
There's no way that can be right!
I mean seriously that CAN'T be right.
Here let me show you.
Hello Internet, welcome to Film Theory, the Velma of YouTube channels.
I'll let you decide exactly what that means.
Today we're taking our first look at the series that taught us that monsters are really just greedy people with access to
Extremely convincing rubber masks. Scooby Doo! A show that sustained itself as a staple of children's cartoon
programming since the late 60s, I mean think about that a show your
Grandparents watched as kids is still relevant today. Next thing
You know, we're gonna be seeing a reboot of the Flintstones with bamm-bamm dabbing and wearing supreme
Yabba Dabba Doo! *dabs*
Hopefully not, but where Scooby, Fred, Velma, Shaggy, and Daphne have found their home lately has been in the memeaverse
Joining the hallowed ranks of Sponge Bob
Shrek and Elon Musk. And of those memes one in particular has impressed us with its power level. Literally
ultra
Instinct shaggy now in case you have better things to do with your time than scour the internet looking for the meme of the week
Heck, that's too generous meme of the day if it's lucky comes one that started at the end of last year and
Really took off back in January
It comes from a somewhat unusual scene in the made-for-tv movie
scooby-doo legend of the phantosaur. Roll that beautiful bean footage
Just your typical cartoon fight scene, right? weeeeell
Kind of, but Shaggy's calm demeanor and his ability to predict his opponents moves
got YouTuber midea to remix the scene with some Dragon Ball super music opening the floodgates to
dozens of spin-off memes and with that a new Z warrior entered the fray. Ultra
instinct shaggy. Fight Goku ultra instinct shaggy holds firm!
Ultra instinct by the way is a reference to the latest and
strongest transformation for Goku in the Dragon Ball series
Basically some intergalactic jelly beans
decide to hold a tournament of power
because, no season of Dragon Balls complete without one of those, across multiple
universes with all the losers getting erased
So to save his universe deus ex goku needs to achieve his new level,
which unlocks all the powers that he's ever had access to
Before as well as any potential power, he still has dormant. It's hard to unlock
It's even harder to master and it comes complete with a brand new hair color for our favorite saiyan, white! here
Everyone was making fun of me with my purple hair. Long story short true to Dragonball tradition
Shaggy becoming a Z warrior prompted all sorts of speculation and joking about his new power level
A petition even went around to get him included into the new Mortal Kombat game Mortal Kombat 11
I mean it didn't happen, but it did prompt this awesome tweet from serious crater at Boone
So I thought I'd try my best at being a Scouter device today to explore what's really going on with Shaggy
How is this character,
Sixty years into his career, been able to harness this newfound power?
And what exactly is that newfound power? Can it be quantified?
What is his power level? To find, out tune in next time to Shaggy ball Z!
Or you can just keep watching this episode of film theory.
To start we'll need to understand the source of Shaggy's powers
You see what makes this meme even more interesting is the fact that Shaggy is always the scared character
He's always the coward. So for him to suddenly become such a skilled fighter is...
unexpected, to say the least.
luckily legend of the phantosaur explains the transition and in case you're wondering about what a
Phantosaur is it is literally a phantom dinosaur. Hey, I can't blame him after 60 years of people wearing rubber masks
You got to start stretching for new ideas
Anyway while on a standard scooby-doo style adventure,
shaggy finds himself locked in a dark cupboard filled with monster masks
This sends him into a catatonic state with the doctor giving him the diagnosis, "acute threat avoidance hypertrophy disorder"
And he's ordered not to investigate any more scary mysteries or even step foot into the Mystery Machine
He told him not to get into the Mystery Machine. That's why I repainted
So to try and cure shaggy from this crippling fear, the gang decides to try hypnosis. "No, it's more like
Hypnosis, but not the boring old-fashioned kind of hypnosis. Psycho luminescent reprogramming.
PLR" the PLR process hypnotizes shaggy so that when he hears the word 'bad'
He literally becomes fearless until he hears the word again
And this isn't nearly as unrealistic as it might first sound.
You see, Shaggy starts out diagnosed with acute threat avoidance
Hypertrophy disorder a disorder that doesn't really exist
but if we break down the meaning of each of those words
we can actually find some pretty similar real-life issues.
Acute just means that the symptoms come on suddenly, threat avoidance is
Obviously referring to Shaggy's overwhelming fear responses
Hypertrophy just means to enlarge. So while cardiac hypertrophy may be problematic because you have an enlarged heart,
muscle hypertrophy would actually be rather
Desirable because you got yourself those gains, son
In this case the enlargement that we're talking about would be of the threat avoidance
Area of the brain which is the amygdala in real life. Amygdala hypertrophy is a real thing
It can occur when someone is suffering the effects of acute stress disorder
similar to and often a precursor to post-traumatic stress disorder sufferers of acute stress disorder find themselves
Overreacting to negative stimuli after some traumatic event just like we see happen with shaggy after he gets himself trapped in that monster
Closet and believe it or not, true to the movie, hypnosis has actually been shown to help reduce the effects of acute stress disorder
So it looks like scooby-doo story here is actually rooted in some real-life science
At least way more real-life science than I ever would have expected. But then how does all this explain him turning into son Goku?
well
The ultra instinct fight scene that started this whole thing
Happens while Shaggy's in one of those fearless states in a movie mister
Hubely makes the point of saying that his PLR is more powerful than your standard versions of hypnosis. "This is completely different"
It's so powerful, in fact that it even reprograms Hubely himself later on in the movie
so it seems likely that what shaggy is undergoing here is a hypnotically induced super saiyan-like
transformation, a concept that for as absurd as it sounds once again, is
unbelievably backed up by
real-world science the soviets back in the 50s and 60s believed so strongly in the power of hypnosis that in the
1956 Olympics they had eleven hypnotists come along with them
It seems ridiculous rights until you start looking at the numbers the Soviets managed to out medal the Americans that year
Ninety-eight medals to 74 now. Obviously, this isn't really a transformation and it's more correlation than it is causation
Otherwise you would see all countries bringing all sorts of hypnotist along with them to the games
Nope
the scientists who studied hypnosis tend to conclude that it helps put athletes into a
flow state a mental state of being fully immersed in the activity that they're doing clearing their mind and putting their
everything into what they're doing at that very moment the crazy thing about all of this is that it's almost
identical to how ultra instinct is described
It's how Goku is able to unlock this new transformation in the first place ultra instinct requires that the fighter
literally stop thinking stop overanalyzing and just exist in the moment, which is why users of it are able to react
Instantaneously to attacks that are happening around them
It's also like Vegeta with his highly analytical mind. It struggles when he tries to master ultra instinct form
He's overthinking. He can't clear his mind enough to enter the necessary flow state
So does that make shaggy the scooby-doo gods your equivalent of Goku Wow
Not quite power levels in the Dragon Ball series are usually determined by Scouter
Devices measuring the amount of ki energy that's possessed by a single character
Although this number should theoretically remain somewhat stable throughout your lifetime
intensive training
Natural aging and form changes such as going super Sam can change your total power levels
Shaggy is still bound by his human limitations and lack of training though
His reaction time certainly is faster when he's in this quote-unquote "ultra instinct mode"
He still needs time to think about how he reacts to attacks and he's missing out on all of those really nifty glow of
So what exactly then is his power level in addition to his fight against the biker gang
Shaggy's other shining moment comes at the end of the movie when he leaps across a river
Jumping up a set of falling rocks to reach a hole in the roof
Shaggy is now jumping from a falling rock and gaining a huge amount of altitude from each jump
So not only is Shaggy having to create enough force to jump from rock to rock
But he's also having to do it before the rock
He's on loses too much of its own altitude user Brenda la on LiveJournal
actually shared a collection of old scooby-doo comics with information about all of the characters and Shaggy's height is given at 6-foot for
1.822 meters. So using Shaggy as a ruler in this shot
We can estimate that shaggy is crossing about 5.5 meters in the course of about three seconds using three separate
Hops shaggy also has to at least maintain his altitude. And in fact, we see him gaining an altitude with the subsequent two
Hops bouncing over a meter off of each rock as he waits for the next rock to fall now
Consider how this needs to work for shaggy in a normal force diagram of jumping the ground isn't moving
So it's exerting a force equal to your weight
Accelerated by gravity into the ground when you want to jump
All you need to do is exert some extra force downward into the ground and that propels you up off of it
But now imagine the ground is also accelerating downwards at the same speed just like we see the falling rocks do in the scene
Sure
You can still jump off of them but actually gaining any additional height is gonna be significantly
harder instead of getting the full
equal and opposite effect of your downward push you now have to account for the fact that the rock is
Falling as well,instead of force equals mass times acceleration
Like it would normally be for any sort of jump now
It becomes force equals mass times acceleration to account for your jump plus mass times gravity to account for the falling rock
We see shaggy hit four rocks in total and three that we see a good measure of his collision time with each of them takes
About two to four frames each about one to two tenths of a second
So if we factor all of this in along with Shaggy's listed 160 pounds or 72.5 kilogram weight
We find that each single leap. That shaggy is making is gonna take an astonishing
5428 Newtons or
1220 pounds of force now in 2014 Žydrūnas Savickas set a world deadlift record of
1155 pounds and Shaggy has to beat that three times in the course of a couple seconds. That is
Superhuman levels of strength not quite the power of flights
But he's getting pretty darn close and in the Dragon Ball universe
Flight or high jumps are definitely something that we can use to help calculate overall power levels
Now the Dragon Ball encyclopedia Kanzenshuu has an incredibly comprehensive
Look at various characters power levels throughout the series which will in turn allow us to give some rough comparisons to ultra instant shaggy
So let's look at Shaggy's power set Shaggy has fast reaction times above average strength and the ability to almost fly
But not quite his jumping ability is just really good and really fast
Where shaggy gets his clearest limitation is not being able to create any sort of energy or ki related blasts
Now look across the franchise's history
The original Dragon Ball series is the only time that we see this level of more grounded
Realistic lighting before power levels started to grow out of control during the 23rd World Martial Arts Tournament
We see Goku square off against his future wife chichi during the course of their sparring
we see her demonstrate many of the same skills that Shaggy uses in the phantosaur movie fast reflexes and
Superhuman jumps but no actual flying. So according to the encyclopedia her power level at the time was
130 the next power level up that we see from there is
139 as showcased by Jackie Chun aka Master Roshi in disguise during the 21st World Martial Arts Tournament here
He demonstrates many similar skills as Chi Chi, fest reflexes, stronger attacks than normal except there is one key difference
Or should I say ki difference? Haha get it? ki difference ki
Anyway in Jackie Chan's battles against both Yamcha and Goku shows his ability to harness ki realtated attacks
Leading to taps the Yamcha battle in particular shows why Shaggy wouldn't be able to hold his own in the fight like this
SS ultra instinct Shaggy's power level is best estimated as comparable to chi chi's level 130
Maybe just slightly more based on that series of extreme jumps
But we definitely know that it's gonna fall somewhere between 130 and 139 man, I feel like a 'your movie sucks' review
It's not a 130 but it's also definitely not a 139. So let's give it a 130 and a half
I might change that number later, but that's what we're gonna go with
Now that being said it's worth noting that all of this is without shaggy doing any training up until this point
He's just been a hippie who lives out in a van running away from mysteries giving a little practice with Master Roshi in the gang
shaggy could absolutely
Ascend reaching higher and higher power levels until finally he's able to
Stay just as useless as the other Z fighters on the sidelines as they watch Goku do all the work
Hey, at least he won't die as much as Krillin. So Shaggy's power level might be a bit disappointing
Definitely not enough to match Goku
but you know where the two are comparable appetites on that one shaggy might truly have
Goku beat but hey, that's just a theory. A Film Theory!!
aaaaaaaaand
Cut!